so with that let me um begin the
proceedings and let patrick get started
thanks michael and jen and uh welcome to
everyone else it's a real pleasure to be
here uh recognized at least one face
from last week in london and uh so i'm
gonna indeed talk a little bit about um
limiting behavior in large networks
and in keeping with the theme i will try
to point out along the way
uh much of what we don't know as well as
a little bit of what we what we do know
in this context
so at a very high level uh mark just uh
sorry mike just talked a little bit
about the workshop goal and i think it's
a laudable one
uh unifying our theoretical and
empirical understanding of uh in
particular large-scale networks
i can say from personal experience that
one of the things that makes this
difficult
for people from the theoretical side is
that getting a hold of rich network data
and the way that we would as
statisticians ordinarily collaborate
with people in other fields is rather
difficult and i think this is because
some of the richest network data tends
to be the same type of data that has the
largest sort of security and privacy
concerns so reproducibility of published
research is is really important in this
area and i would say that it can be very
difficult at times to
really learn a lot about network data in
depth if
if data sets remain proprietary and i
think we should all work to
to try to do what we can to help
overcome that barrier
from the more mathematical point of view
so my interests and what i think the
field needs is a coherent asymptotic
framework for network analysis
and i think to have any kind of coherent
mathematical theory you need three main
ingredients
for the theory to be relevant and
inspired
you need mechanisms that generate data
right so clearly we have that in spades
i think there's no question about that
and at least half of us here are
intimately familiar with that
but we also need two other things we
need structure mathematical structure
that facilitates analysis right so we
need mathematical mechanisms and
formalisms that help us understand
how to put a variety of potentially
disparate objects into a common
framework and make sense out of them
right and then the third thing we need
are tools tools that flow from this
mathematical structure and it's
important that the properties of these
tools can be understood
we need to be able to have an
understanding of everything from
statistical sufficiency on one hand to
um you know algorithmic guarantees and
run times on another there's a very
challenging area uh outside of the
network's context uh bringing these two
requirements together is something that
that michael's talked about and written
about recently and uh and in general i
think that there's quite a lot of
progress to be made in this area
so anyway so those are the three things
i think we need and as i said right now
i would say we have one of them in
spades the other two are
are racing to catch up
so you can think of networks as big data
if you like
and uh if i remember right the simon's
logo at the moment to sort of oh of data
or something like this so it seems like
a good opportunity to to talk about this
uh what i've given you at the top here
are
three renderings of adjacency matrices
of real networks and maybe they're large
maybe they're not it depends on how
large you have to think n has to be to
be truly large
but basically these are just sort of
pixelated images
where i've listed the rows and columns
of an adjacency matrix and i've colored
colored the corresponding diagram black
if there's an edge between the i j
node and white otherwise and that's in
keeping with the notation that i've
defined there
so typically when we want to make sense
of these things from an asymptotic
statistics framework we start with the
simplest possible non-trivial model
and usually to keep things easy we
assume that at some level there's some
independence in the data
and so particularly what we typically
assume is that the links are somehow
obtained as coin tosses in the simplest
setting right and you know the model
promulgated by erdos and others is very
very simple it has one single parameter
which is the the you know the biasedness
of a coin and we just toss a coin and
choose two times and we get and choose
two edges or non-edges and everything's
good um but of course the challenge in
statistics is to understand how do we
couple the tosses in a sort of uh richer
more complex way right if i have n
choose two independent parameters and
only n choose two observations i can't
really make inference in any sort of
useful way right on the other hand one
parameter surely isn't enough
so i thought i would start by
talking a little bit about the um
the uh
the sort of the simplest possible
framework for for pushing past these
basic models right
and what i want to think about and what
i'd like to ask you to think about is
the following question um
how do we take a
a finite discrete combinatorial object a
graph
and turn it into
or pass to an infinite dimensional
analytical object instead okay how do we
go from a network to a function
and there's many ways that one could
think about doing this but it turns out
there's at least one way that's
particularly nice and it'll be covered
in detail by uh by peter later so i
won't talk very much about it uh but it
will get a mention a little bit later um
and i'm interested in the case where we
have three basic assumptions
so i'm going to say real networks
typically exhibit these properties and i
think some of that at least is open to
challenge but as we look for a balance
of mathematical tractability and
practical utility these three
assumptions are workable okay so the
first one is that our networks of
interest are often large so we're
interested in large sample limits
how large does n have to be depends on
the complexity of your model
depending on how you couple the edges in
the network
you know your effective sample size
could be as great as order n squared or
just barely larger than order n
right
i'm going to assume that many networks
of interest are sparse
i think there's good empirical evidence
for this
and so what i'm going to say in this
framework in this asymptotic framework
is just that i'm going to make sure to
allow my edge probabilities or marginal
probability of an edge
to be a little o of one okay
and then finally in practice
at some level we often need to model a
lack of information
and one way to think about this is to
imagine that we're interested in models
for graphs that are essentially
unlabeled
so
if two graphs are isomorphic to one
another it means that they're the same
equivalent up to relabeling
and it's important to have asymptotic
regimes that respect this type of
invariance okay so in other words
if you give me the data set and the
order in which you list the nodes
conveys no information then i can think
about what you've given me as kind of
like an unlabeled graph right often in
practice as in the example i've shown
here we kind of play a game where we
have covariate information about for
example the and here the political
affiliations of the nodes in this
network we sort of hold out that
information and we create a kind of
clustering problem where we try to
recover it but at some level just like
we use
iidness and ordinary statistical
modeling
we have to kind of have a way to model a
lack of information right and and
thinking of the graphs as unlabeled as
one way to do this and i know it's
something that peter bickle's going to
talk about later on in the week
so if you take these three assumptions
you can begin to ask yourself or how do
these inform our thinking
and as michael alluded to
one thing you can take away from these
three basic assumptions
is that it is possible to write down a
natural limit object for a graph
that respects these three assumptions
and you get something akin to what we
would call infill asymptotics so think
about time series as the number of time
series points that i observe goes to
infinity
i can choose to do the analysis on the
unit interval and imagine that my sort
of sampling interval is something like 1
over n right as n goes to infinity i'm
just you know i'm dilating
more and more finally into the unit
interval right and so the idea here is
going to be very much the same the
notion will be that as the network size
grows to infinity i imagine these
representations that i showed you before
converging in some well-defined sense to
a function defined on the unit square
okay so i mean it's almost like going
from a you know a digital image you know
back to the analog world if you want to
think about it that way
and of course life isn't that easy
uh for many reasons uh so largeness we
would we would then be covered that's
great but sparsity causes problems
because of things like effective sample
size how much information is really in
the data as n grows and also because of
this this issue of permutation and
variance
i chose of course very very special
orderings for these three data sets if
we had more time i could tell you about
them but it's a social network a
co-authorship network and a student
survey network
and in order to reveal this type of
structure i had to choose a very
particular labeling for this graph
otherwise you wouldn't be able to see
anything right
so um if we begin at the simplest
non-trivial model that i started telling
you about before
uh we could imagine doing the following
so we jump up from a single parameter
which would give me an erdos-renyi type
of graph
to end parameters one per node
and if you're in social sciences and you
want to think about this as a a
model-based version of degree centrality
you can do that so you can think about
each node having a propensity for
connection and in the standardization
i've taken here these are normalized so
every node gets a pi i
pi i is between 0 and 1. and then i
simply form connections
independently by taking the product of
pi i and pi j so i have some propensity
for connection michael has some
propensity for connection we shake hands
and with probability given by the
product of our propensities we you know
link each other on facebook or whatever
and so this is obviously a very very
simple model
and that yields some pros uh for example
it's clear to see that if i take pi pi
transpose i get basically the mean
matrix of the underlying adjacency
structure so i have a nice separable
rank one model
and it also turns out that the network
degrees which i can get just by summing
out across the rows of the adjacency
structure are sufficient to consistently
estimate this vector pi
and there's a number of ways you can
think about that many people have
written about it peter is going to talk
about it later this week
basically
this is not the exact maximum likelihood
estimator because it's uh you think of
this as a log linear model and you'll
see right away that the maximum
likelihood estimator can't be written
down in closed form but nevertheless you
can show that you know to within a
universal constant depending on sparsity
and some other things you know you can
basically i mean the degrees are
essentially sufficient here
and you get there's other interesting
behavior you can get asymptotic
normality in certain regimes you can get
phase transitions as the sparsity of the
network shifts from you know dense to
quasi-sparse to appreciably a sparse to
extremely sparse to ultra sparse and you
know i mean we can we can make up more
more phrases all the way right down
almost to the poisson limit okay
the cons so the cons are in some sense
the same thing
when you have a model for which there
exists a simple sufficient statistic
this tells you that that sufficient
statistic captures all the structure
that you can express with that model
right so it's not often in life that we
believe that a real data set would be
well fitted by this type of model
that's why you often see it show up in
graph clustering problems where it's a
sort of natural null right nobody
believes the null but it turns out that
you can think of doing
sort of non-parametric anomaly detection
uh fitting a graph under this type of
null and then looking for patterns and
the residuals sort of the deviance
residuals and they'll often tell you
something uh to wit you know modularity
have a look at uh mark newman's
modularity functional and you'll see
exactly the expected value of pa pij
under the null you know appearing in the
functional
so the other problem of course is that
it's not really clear how to specify pi
that could be a weakness that could be a
strength i'm going to say that from the
point of view of practitioners it's not
really clear right
if i can't specify pi how do i put down
a good model right a compelling or
believable model even if it's just a
null model so here's something you can
do
you can increase the heterogeneity
of this very very simple sort of degree
centrality model
by doing the following thing by adding a
level of modeling hierarchy
so
you can think of this as being bayesian
if if you like if it suits you
nothing will be harmed
suppose we give pi a prior
right so i'll let each pi i be i id from
some
let's say density for now g doesn't have
to be a density but uh but that makes it
easier the way that i've written it and
then i'll allow myself the opportunity
to scale down
the resulting probability of an edge
by some value rho n
so this is purely for
modeling convenience let's say to
capture the fact that as n goes to
infinity if my pies remain order one
i'm going to get
degrees that grow linearly with n in
expectation and that's not going to give
me a structure that's very consistent
with what we observe in real world
networks right so row n is just a
scaling parameter and that's why i've
shown its dependence on n
and the nice thing about this model is
if i want to i can just think about the
inverse cdf method and i can instead
write down pij directly
as again row n scaling and now i take
the inverse of the cdf of my density g
and i evaluate it at two independent
uniforms psi i and psi j
right so go across the whole network let
each node now have a latent uniform
variable psi
and
i've just basically by the inverse cdf
method rewritten this degree centrality
model with an extra layer of hierarchy
so is that interesting is that helpful
it depends on your point of view
the good news is that we sort of
added some
potential for over dispersion or
heterogeneity
perhaps the bad news if you want to
think about it is that still somehow
there is a kind of reproduction of g
directly in the network degrees
uh so the way to think about this result
is just
the probability that any given degree d
i takes a value k it ends up being
asymptotically equivalent to this uh
density g that we began with evaluated
at a at a scaled point the sort of k
over n times mu n where mu n is just the
overall expected edge probability
and that's basically telling you
something that the probabilists have
known for a long time which is that
as the network gets larger
the values of the degrees tend to
concentrate around the the sort of prior
distribution that we started with okay
and one can make this i mean i didn't
bother to write it but one can
one can make the statement much more
precise with
uh
a multiplicative error bound and and
other kind of niceties but the essential
point is just that asymptotically we
sort of haven't added that much in a way
because we we get right back to where we
started so again this is really telling
you like
i started with something that was rank
one and at the end of the day when n
gets large like
uh as long as i'm not you know and if i
set row n to zero obviously this isn't
going to work right but in any
reasonable regime this is basically
going to be what's happened happening
all the way down to the poisson limit if
i set mu n to 1 over n or some constant
over n a theorem of this type will still
hold so all the way down to the to the
limiting case where i have order one
degrees as n goes to infinity
is it do you mean that the serum is only
true for k
smaller than
n times mu n uh no there's something i
wasn't going to talk about but since in
the spirit of open discussion
there is a cut-off effect and the cutoff
effect come from sampling
i don't mean sampling like network
subsampling i mean like sampling
distribution so in other words i have pi
i pi j
i generate an edge but the product of
two numbers less than one is always less
than one and so when i instantiate this
model like i'm not going to observe you
know with with high probability with
okay with exponentially large
probability or probability tending
exponentially to one i'm not going to
get very much far past what the mean of
pi i and pi j are going to give me so
there's a kind of cutoff effect if i
would have written this differently i
would have actually written the survival
function of a binomial here and it
basically looks like um
well
it converges eventually in some sense in
in in in total variation to the
indicator and it basically looks
something like this
so what you get is the product of two
things you get the density that you
started with which i don't know maybe it
looked like this
and then you get the product of these
two functions together and so what will
happen in practice is that it'll look
exactly like g and then all of a sudden
there'll be an exponential cut off
and one can explain other models that
have appeared in the literature
that add parameters to explain this
exponential cutoff in terms of what i've
just written down for you so when i say
it's a consequence of sampling i mean
that you know basically um bernoulli
variability you know does something to
you right you can't just uh you can't
just ignore that step in the process or
you won't get
you won't get the right answer
asymptotically
so uh so there we go
so now uh and in which graphons finally
arrive so this has been lurking under
the surface the whole time um what is
this fundamental limit object that i've
been talking about um well
if you take the example i just gave you
which was rank one and we kind of you
know convexify things and just think of
taking a sum of
of k uh
inverse cdfs then clearly i can play the
same game right and the reason i've
bothered to make this a convex
combination is just so that i keep the
overall sort of um balance of things
here the same
and once you've done that you have to
ask yourself well like why am i
bothering you know it's like okay like
mercer's theorem is begging me to do
something here right like why am i
bothering to just stop at a at a a fixed
finite uh expansion right
and so uh and the theory of graph limits
which is something we'll hear more about
today um low watch and co-authors
introduced uh the idea of something
called a graph on
and a graph graphon is just a a term for
a function
defined on the unit square
that okay it has to be measurable
otherwise we can't really do much in
in probability terms and uh we're going
to let it be bounded and that helps take
care of some problems later
but basically
if the function is also positive and
symmetric then i why don't i just write
down a model for pij that just scales
this graph on function f okay you give
many any symmetric uh bounded measurable
positive function on the unit square i
will come up with a scaling regime such
that the pijs lie between zero and one
with probability one and we're off to
the races okay
so why would you want to do this uh who
cares is it a good idea etc etc uh so i
will i will tell you a little bit of
what i think of these things
after first just pointing out that now
we're going to get rid of the previous
interpretation and renormalize things so
that i recover row n as the is the
probability of an edge directly and
that's just a way of saying if i want to
dial in the asymptotic sparsity regime
of interest i can do it directly by
controlling row n it doesn't really
matter how i normalize f i'm going to
treat f as if it's a probability density
and just go ahead and normalize it
as i would a probability measure
so what does this let you do well
if you take a step back
ask yourself what we know about large
graph limits
so one thing we know is uh zamaretti's
regularity lemma so the regularity lemma
says
in essence that
eventually
graphs that are sufficiently large
start to behave like
in some sense
they can be subdivided into regular
groups
blocks that behave similarly or quasi
randomly if you want to think about it
that way
and this regular dilemma has been the
has received a lot of attention in in
the pure communities
not just in combinatorics but also in um
in number theory and an analysis
and uh and and summary uh at his uh abel
prize lecture uh
this was referenced it's from two years
ago it was now um
so this thing this has motivated people
to think about
dealing with networks that have large
block-like structure
and one result in this direction that
i'll just mention briefly to kind of set
up what i'm going to tell you next is
that
if
such a model is in force
and the number of blocks
or groups is controlled
so it doesn't go too quickly
then as long as the graph is
not all the way at the poisson limit
one can consistently recover the groups
and uh so i've worked on this problem
karl roy has worked on this problem it
fits into the
program on spectral graph theory that
was mentioned at the beginning of the
talk
and
and that's kind of basic flavor of
result but
when we wrote this paper we assumed that
a block model was in force this is
called a block model
and that for example you know i knew the
number of blocks and all these things
and uh and that's fine that's sort of
traditional
you know standard frequencies to
asymptotic analysis where you assume a
correctly specified model you turn the
handle and you ask what maximum
likelihood or profile likelihood will do
for you
the more interesting thing is that i can
also fit this model under model
misspecification
so i can drop the assumption that the
generative process is a block model
and i can go back to the graph on
assumption i gave you on the previous
page right
i'm not going to worry about sparsity
for now
because that's a complicating factor but
it turns out that even if you fit a
block model to an arbitrary graph on
function f
then you get a kind of oracle inequality
oracle inequality tells you that
eventually the data the noisy bernoulli
data they sort of yield up information
on f
and for this result to hold
f just needs to be measurable
definitely doesn't need to be a block
model i don't need to know anything
about it i just know that it needs to be
measurable
and
before this result the only result that
was known
had a logarithmic convergence rate and
that's basically down to zemeretti's
lemma zamaretti's lemma tells you
something about the sort of uniform
approximability of such things
so we improve this to polynomial rate we
don't know right now which functions if
any functions attain this rate
it certainly looks conservative in all
the things that we come up with but but
you know i mean you could there's all
kinds of things one could potentially do
here so uh yeah question
yeah so i'll explain it in a couple of
slides um
it goes back to a ques something i
raised at the beginning which is this
issue of permutation and variance so one
has to define a metric
that
looks at
sort of like the integrated mean square
error of f but allows for
all possible rearrangements of the x and
y axes so
yeah so this is related to the cut
metric uh exactly yes uh thank you uh so
yeah
thanks
so um so there you go so yes this is
essentially the cut metric you can think
of it as the cut metric
and for those of you who aren't familiar
with the cut metric it's exactly what i
said we sort of allow ourselves to
rearrange the x and y axes arbitrarily
and we take the infimum overall
rearrangements right
so how does this work well
the basic idea is you fit this block
model idea that i described before
and a block model is basically just
collecting or aggregating nodes into
groups looking at the corresponding sets
of edges as blocks and taking sample
proportions over these blocks
right
so uh
i'm going to let z be the function that
indicates which block a given node is in
so zi is in block a for example and i'm
going to use h to to count the size of
each
of each group of nodes right and then
i'll call capital h the sort of
cumulative distribution function that
arises if i think of ordering the blocks
in a nice way like the pictures i showed
you and then basically you know stepping
through from one block to the next
so this this h inverse of u could be
used as a generative model at just as i
use g inverse in the slides that i
showed you earlier right
so we're just about done
i want to just give you one final result
here and then we can talk later about
pros and cons
i'm going to define my non-parametric
estimator of f
by using the sample proportions over
these blocks
and so all i do is i use this capital h
function to just extend my block model
so that it's defined on everywhere on on
zero one cross zero one and i i
estimated throw n hat by just counting
how many edges are in the network and um
and dividing by n choose two
so the main result is that um
if you fit a block model by profile
likelihood
and if things are not too nasty then you
can get a kind of universality of
approximation
so what i do is i think of you know
fitting a sequence of these models
i force the number of blocks to grow
within
and i control
the average group size or the maximum
and the minimum group size kind of to my
advantage
and then as long as i'm not too sparse
so as long as
sorry that's not actually poly login
that's the degrees need to grow as
polylog n
as long as i obey these conditions
then i can get convergence in the cut
metric
and the main conditions that i need are
that the effective sample size of every
block has to grow rapidly enough that
things behave asymptotically normally
okay so that's why i have to make sure
that the expected number of edges in the
smallest block is lower bounded by
something that grows faster than log n
and on the other hand i need to make
sure that the the kind of largest or
average block size isn't so large that
um
that i'm not sort of zooming in
gradually on this function that's
defined on 0 1 cross 0 1.
so i won't go into all the details of
where these terms come from but
you basically to get a result like this
to work it helps to have a kind of
uniform continuity so
alpha tells you
how smooth your function f is it's the
holder constant or the sorry the holder
exponent and you pay a price according
to that smoothness or that lack of
smoothness
you pay a standard profile likelihood a
price for not knowing the parameters in
the model and then you pay a third price
uh to get the convergence of these
underlying psi uniform random variables
that i talked about a few slides ago so
i'll stop there uh that's kind of where
we are in this way of thinking and i
think we're i know we're going to hear
some more about this this morning but um
let me let me bring it to a close there
and uh thank you very much we can
whatever you like thanks
i guess unless there are short technical
questions or clarifications why don't we
move on and then say save it for the for
the general discussion
okay so i think next week